Hello Freak bitches.
So,
uh,
when you would shake his hand,
shake it like that.
He has like a little little hook.
I'm like a baby finger.
Yeah.
It's like constantly,
that was a toe that was a toe.
It's a toe,
but now it's his index finger.
But he had his toe.
Yeah.
His foot,
his foot only has was four toes as a
toe,
the big toe and then three hangers and
somebody bid it off in a CC fight.
Yeah.
Oh that reminds me,
that reminds me so much fun that I was
with Diaz for three days.
Yes.
And we're the,
I'll tell you why because this is so
perfect.
So I'm with the,
as we're leaving the shoreline
amphitheater,
we did the odd ball tour.
So we're leaving the shoreline
amphitheatre he just,
he massacred,
he,
you know,
it was like close to 10,000
people we get in the shuttle because
there's intermission and joey and I were
before intermission.
So we tell the driver we want to go back
to hotel.
There's still another half of show to
go.
So it was just joey,
myself,
and the driver.
And we get in the car,
there's no music on,
we're just talking and we just hit one
of those moments.
You know when you're on a highway at
night and you kind of hit that thing
where it's like you just,
everyone stops talking for a minute and
you're looking out the window and you
can feel like I'm just kind of staring
off.
No one's talking.
And then after like 15 seconds of
silence,
Joey goes,
that would tell you about the time I saw
a guy cut open at the tenderloin in 1979
his stomach split wide open and I was
like,
what?
And I just see the driver's eyes widened
and I was like,
no.
He goes,
yeah,
it's blood was brown because he was
bleeding for so long.
People just stepped over him and I saw
two guys stab each other in the fucking
street,
1980 just over nothing.
They just stab each other.
I didn't know.
I almost shit my pants but then I got
used to it and then you just see the
drag.
It was just crazy.
I got used to it.
Just look over like who's this guy I'm
sitting next to me,
which is all you saw from like uh,
he was,
he's such a like a rocket ship of a
personality that you get used to like
all the people on this tour because I
did all the dates and then they you,
cause you should see like the first
night he came out I'd see the like the
odd ball staff like turning and like
what the fuck is going on because his,
he's just so out of left field,
you know,
you can't prepare for it.
And he's just like,
he's got not a fucking his tank.
There's nothing just cause people cock
suckers like the audience,
what's up cock suckers.
They're like,
who the fuck he did it to 8,000
people last night.
What's up?
You fucking cock suckers.
Yeah,
it's endearing.
See of live.
Yeah.
He even asked,
he has like some reference to it.
Like he knew that he,
he cause he,
he would throw people off.
Right.
You could tell that some people they'd
be like,
oh my God.
And then he goes,
yeah,
I say some fucked up shit.
And then,
and then he goes,
but me,
uncle Joey,
you know everyone's got an uncle joey
like me.
It's a little uncomfortable at first,
like a finger in your ass.
And then they just like laughing again
right away.
He gets how he hits people,
you know?
Yeah.
He's something odd.
I've never been anybody like him before.
It's a force of nature.
It's like a rare occurrence.
Really owns his farts in public.
It really sparked game strong.
He dropped.
He was just like,
I gotta tell you something else,
mom at a bar.
I was like so loud and it smelled so
sour.
And he goes,
wait until it hits that motherfucker
points at the guy.
Yeah,
man.
It's crazy,
It's so crazy.
He's married.
He's,
he wants on a plane that was so bad that
I head phones on and I smelled.
I was in the middle of writing and I
smelled it.
And I just go,
oh right.
And then I start to make this face and
then I go and I put my shirt and my nose
is terrible,
and then it hits the woman behind us
with the headphones.
I'm listening to music.
I hear,
Oh my God.
He's got his hands rested.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
He got credit for it too.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Cause I do it on planes,
but I keep it private.
I don't obtain credit and no one assumes
I would.
Right.
So I like to,
plus the sound.
It's so much on the plane that you can
fart and you can just let it rip.
No one's going to hear it.
Yeah.
It's good quality.
He also says things that don't add up
for that.
Like he would like,
he,
I'm like,
come on.
He goes,
you know me dog.
All right.
It's like my favorite thing about his
periscopes,
he'll smoke,
you know,
crazy amounts of weed.
He's like,
at six o'clock in the morning,
I've always like rolled two joints,
smoked him.
Fuck,
are you doing with your life?
And I'm like,
I go,
you're lying.
That's the accomplishment.
Like I'm doing something.
What are you doing?
Okay.